amerikaner europäer und russen die
gemeinsame sache machen an einem strang
ziehen das war einmal aber es gibt dann
einen ort an dem das noch so ist oder
zumindest sein muss im weltall nämlich
aktuell auf der iss der internationalen
raumstation dort aktuell auch wieder an
bord amerikaner und russen ganz
gemeinsam und die raumstation unter
kontrolle von amerikanern europäern und
russland gleich machen sich rar yakari
und keiler berhane zwei us astronauten
in wenigen minuten in den weltraum auf
einer außen mission und wir nehmen sie
mit ein stück weit auf diese
spektakuläre außenmissionen die nasa
überträgt das ganze diesen
weltraumspaziergang nämlich live und
diese bilder wollen wir ihnen zeigen
sehen sie hier oben rechts auch schon
eingehakt bei uns weil man fragt sich
natürlich wie ist das auf so engem raum
aus zwei verschiedenen ländern
angesichts dieses konfliktes jetzt und
das fragen wir jemanden der das schon
erlebt hat auf so engem raum weit weit
weg von der erde professor ulrich weiter
ist wissenschafts astronaut und uns
jetzt auch zugeschaltet schönen guten
tag herr weiter in schönberg man fragt
sich gelingt es dort oben im alter
tatsächlich
probleme wie politik völlig aus sachen
die sonst menschen einen oder völlig in
zweien können und dann ist man auf so
engem raum gibt es themen von denen man
sagt 'die besprechen wir da oben nicht
das bleibt außen vor hier oben sind wir
alle einfach nur eins und zwei
astronauten
ja so ist es eigentlich es ist wie zu
hause auch man redet ganz normal
übrigens auch mit freunden
unterschiedliche nationen die
astronauten kommen immer hervorragend
miteinander zurecht interesse uns ja
auch einmal pro jahr weltweit das klappt
alles super genauso auf der raumstation
natürlich redet man über solche themen
man in zwei sich nicht darüber das wäre
auch menschlich verdammt schwierig weil
man halt nicht weg kann auch wenn heute
kurzfristig man mal aussteigen darf man
muss ja schon wieder zurückkommen herr
professor walter aber das ist ja das
eine wie das menschliche untereinander
funktioniert dahinter stehen ja die
staaten ohne die staatliche
unterstützung wäre das alles gar nicht
möglich das heißt auf der im einer ist
sozusagen putin auf dem anderen ohr joe
biden das kann doch wahnsinnig
kompliziert werden in den nächsten tagen
in den nächsten wochen nach so vielen
jahren in denen es ganz klar war dass
man an einem strang zieht ja das stimmt
würden die politik ins spiel kommt dann
wird schwierig sie haben das vielleicht
gehört der roma ziehen das ist der
leiter der russischen raumfahrt
organisation antritt abgesetzt nachdem
beiden gesagt hat hat man zu wenn er nie
aus ukraine verschwindet dann könnten
wir die kooperation auf der raumstation
beenden immerhin hat der europa ziehen
aus wut gesagt das könnt ihr gerne
machen denn dann könnt ihr die
raumstation nicht mehr abheben dann
lassen wir sie auf die usa stürzen also
sowas hat eben auch schon gegeben was
natürlich nicht stimmt übrigens da hat
der rocco 10 gelogen aber sie sehen wenn
die politik ins spiel kommt dann wird so
richtig gemacht auf der raumstation iss
so was überhaupt kein thema wir wissen
ihre operationen kann vor anderthalb
jahren nicht runter kommen weil sie in
einer gewissen höhe schwebt die fällt
nicht einfach runter also gesehen auch
politik wird im bild vorn gemacht aber
man bleibt da oben als astronaut
ziemlich ruhig wir sehen während wir
sprechen die livebilder vielleicht kann
sie uns gleich noch erzählen was sagen
da passiert vorher würde ich aber gerne
von ihnen wissen stellt man denn
irgendwelche regeln auf sie sagten es
ist ein bisschen so wie zu hause und
auch da gibt es ja regeln stellt man
diese auch auf also das heißt wenn sich
jemand daneben dann kriegt man da aus
zeit oder so was ich weiß es nicht gibt
es irgendetwas wie man das zusammenleben
dort regelt wenn es dann doch mal
eskaliert egal ob es um politik geht
oder vielleicht darum wer das letzte
snickers so dumm ist ja dort ist
natürlich kein rechtsfreier raum
tatsächlich ist es so es gilt das gesetz
des moduls in dem man sich befindet es
gibt also ein russisches und es gibt ein
amerikanisches modell gibt europäisches
modul über allem steht der commander der
commander hat das letzte wort also egal
wer unten auf dem boden irgendwas sagt
er entscheidet was dann gemacht wird es
kommt natürlich auch vor dass es
streitigkeiten oben auf der raumstation
gibt nicht jetzt wegen wo keine und
russland sondern manchmal deswegen sehr
persönliche angelegenheit
es gab zum beispiel eine situation wo
der eine kollege zueinander gesagt hat
und wenn er nicht gleich verschwindet
dann schon ein außenfenster was
natürlich nicht geht also solche
situationen gibt es auch die situation
die wir jetzt gerade hier im bild sehen
das ist das sogenannte pre briefing das
heißt bevor man überhaupt daraus ziehen
kann in den weltraum muss man sich den
raum anzug anziehen dass insbesondere
raumanzug für diese außenbordeinsätze
und die haben nur 0,3 bar innendruck
damit man sich relativ gut bewegen kann
da ist reiner sauerstoff können und
deswegen muss man dieses rating machen
das heißt man atmet über viele stunden
lang nur reinen sauerstoff damit man den
druck im raumanzug absenken kann ist
also ein ziemlich lange prozedur sieht
man aus dem weltall den krieg
ja dann kann man sehen nicht die panzer
sondern die man kann sehr deutlich die
rauchentwicklungen sehen rauchfahnen
wenn aus dem bild haben sehr deutlich zu
sehen also im augenblick oder vor kurzem
gerade der etwa wenn der asche und feuer
spuckt das kann man sehen und diese
rauchschwaden die wir jetzt in den
bildern sehen die kann man aus dem
bildraum wunderbar sehen dass also die
bilder des weges sie uns nicht nur hier
beschäftigen sondern bis so weit oben
gehen bis ins weltall gehen wo man sich
jetzt gerade live vorbereitet einen
weltraumspaziergang zu machen dort wo
russland und die usa weiterhin eng
zusammen arbeiten müssen egal was auf
der erde passiert ich kann mir
vorstellen für professor walter man
sieht von dort oben vielleicht den rauch
vielleicht dass der krieg stattfindet
aber hatten sie das gefühl dass
russische und auch amerikanische
astronauten dann doch vielleicht geeint
werden da oben mit dem blick auf die
erde und dem wunsch nach frieden
das ist ja eines beiden sinne der
raumstation nicht nur wissenschaftler
toben zu machen sondern sie war für alle
nationen immer das symbol der
gemeinsamen menschheit als vorposten
dort draußen gemeinsam einen vorposten
machen und deswegen glaube ich auch
nicht dass dort oben wirklich die
astronauten sich in zweien werden weil
wir alle wissen wir sind gemeinsam
glauben sie mir wenn sie dort oben
runter schauen und keine grenzen sehen
sie sehen natürlich keine grenze
zwischen ukraine und russland auch keine
grenze zwischen polen und irgendwas
überhaupt keine grenze und dann fragt
man sich die kann das sein dass der
mensch da unten krieg wird obwohl es
doch eigentlich von natur aus keine
grenzen und dann wird einem klar diese
grenzen dieses enkeln das existiert nur
in unserem kopf das gibt es eigentlich
gar nicht und man fragt sich wie kann
der mensch so was machen wenn sie das
mit eigenen augen sehen dann wird einem
klar welchen quatsch den menschen machen
ja und wie klein das alles ist wie klein
dieser putins angriffskrieg wie
vielen dank an professor walter für
diese eindrücke vielleicht noch mal ganz
kurz oben rechts drauf geschaut ganz
kurz gesagt was da gerade passiert im
livebild im weltall
ja sie bereitet sich gerade auf den
außenbordeinsatz vor dh der eine hat
schon sein anzug angezogen das ist eine
ziemlich längliche angelegenheit und
dann müssen die stundenlang darin reinen
sauerstoff atmen damit nämlich der
innendruck im anzug abgesenkt werden
kann nur so kann sich der anzug relativ
leicht bewegt werden die bewegung im
vakuum des weltraums ist eine ganz
wichtige angelegenheit sonst kann man
nicht richtig arbeiten das ist also das
ist denn da aus dieser röhre nämlich an
rauskommt der flex und kabel um das ist
nämlich an die sauerstoffzufuhr dafür
brauchen
nein das ist nicht das ist ein
kommunikationskabel es heißt die
astronauten müssen natürlich ständig mit
der bodenkontrolle sprechen also darüber
läuft die kommunikation in dieses rating
ist noch ein bisschen was anderes ein
ziemlich dicker schlauch das ist
ungefähr so dick er läuft am anzug
entlang und dann hinten am rücken an die
wand den kann man im augenblick nicht
sehen wir tun so als hätten wir es
verstanden aber super erklärt professor
1 3 beim nicht mehr so machen wer
braucht denn werden wir sprechen sitzt
der kollege die ganze zeit da und wird
geprüft und mit sauerstoff versorgt also
es scheint eine längere geschichte zu
sein ist klingt doch locker
weltraumspaziergang aber es bedarf in
vorbereitung herr professor reiner danke
ihnen sehr gehen heute stehen dort oben
die letzten eindrücke von der reise es
von der internationalen raumstation wo
amerikaner russen europäer ganz hängen
auf engstem raum zusammen arbeiten das
war mal ein zeichen an die welt wie man
kooperiert und mittlerweile ist das die
letzte enge kooperation dieser ja
nationen dort ganz im weltall